benjamin castaldi 6-3 tue l'amour aux
premières beit les règles
merci tu les vois
[Musique]
c'est déjà l'exemple de répartiteurs on
est là on va faire toute une partie sans
castaldi et après lolo son régime il
donnera les réponses à catane d'accord
pour le moment c'est pour vous attention
c'est parti géraldine maillet sic 3 tue
l'amour aux premières dates je suis de
la gueule il a des mains sales et puis
des pieds pour dénoncer
des tongs je ne participe pas cette
hausse est à dire qu elle soit cadets et
fut avec
ses tons gand liège attention attention
de lambeaux ouais 6,3 x 6,3 façon de
ruiner une soirée romantique
comment 6 3 face aux de ruminer une
soirée romantique
elle les épées et l'autre
et on a dit qu'il avait narré paris est
ce que ce sera au cordeau d'accord bien
que moi mais
à l'époque
jeune âge que pose la même question 6-3
façon de ruiner romantique et pue de la
gueule
m
lamothe 121,20 qui pue de la gueule et
calcul
[Applaudissements]
s'exclamait est parti doucement et la
reine ajouté des trucs à
la demande et je vais demander je
prenais mes questions à peine âgée à
isabelle morini-bosc 6-3 façon de ruiner
une soirée romantique venir de chamakh
est là sa rage entre les dents il a un
appareil dentaire et effectivement il
pue de la gueule ouais
tu vois même pas compter sur aussi c'est
que toi tu es là pour montrer que qui
souhaitait regarder belcaire la question
ces trois passants de running de soi il
me prend pas pendant toute la soirée de
son ex il ne me fait pas de compliments
et une pile il est quoi
allait pas bien
est ce que
monsieur question les tractations
question pour guillaume genton vous
allez tous en boîte ce soir qui se fait
recaler pourquoi agile comme le regarder
d'accord il à faire ensuite je rendrai
qui veulent à bernard isa sauf si c'est
un ehpad
c'est méchant il est méchant c'est
méchant homme sans blesser
si elle a entendu ce que tu as dit
bernard montiel s'alcooliser ou pas lol
ouais je vois pas l'asie doucement le
talent est au bilan
regardez montiel explique de façon
innocente at on est enfant comme on fait
des bébés
et ben tu mets ce que tu as entre les
jambes dans le
jeu les fleurs et puis tu expliques
mais moi ils sont tous connus largement
question je pose la même question
matthieu delormeau à
la haye smic de façon innocente at on
enfin commenté les bébés à et bientôt on
a lot
[Applaudissements]
alors alors alors ah ben maison
en
faisant l'amour à la baisse annoncé que
je dis c'est pas dit cela il faut des
guerriers non parce qu'on voit les
abeilles avec les
tuyaux placés au placard sur ce clash
open
kata d'ici là trois résolutions que ta
prise et que tu as n'a jamais tenus
comment économiser de l'argent
est fidèle voilà au malawi ja oui bah
oui
tu économises pas mal d'argent
et donc de pousser théorie n'est pas
fidèle aujourd'hui non mais avant mais
c'est pas un jeu du tout ça mais si on
avait de leurs books est
pas forcément la wii aujourd'hui c'est
un fait mais tous leurs maux c'est le
cas
des records d'audience depuis la rentrée
cela qui passaient sans but
on s'est rendu compte de quelques chants
et très drôle chiffre à chaque fois et
mathieu deux hommes au népal enfin
record de noix
[Applaudissements]